من بيروت معنا العميد الياس حنان الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك سيد الياس
هل من مبررات ميدانيه عسكريه لهذا
الانسحاب
الروسي المعلن من الضفه اليمنى لنهر
دينيبر في خيصه
بالطبع حسن هذا الامر اتى على لسان
الجنرال المعين جديده
الذي قال انه لا يمكن البقاء في هذه
المرحله في خرسان يعني نتحدث اليوم الضفه
الغربيه حيث الروس هناك مساحه 9.000 كلم
مربع تقريبا فيها ما يقارب ال 20 الى
25,000 جندي لا يمكن الدفاع عنها لانه
طبيعه الارض لا تسمع بهذا الامر والانسحاب
من المدينه ليان الانسحاب من الاقليم لانه
بقي ما يقارب 18,000 كم يعطي مدخل همم الى
البحر الاسود الى
شبه جزيره قرب وبالتالي تامين المياه كما
تم الحديث عنه اعتقد هناك تغيير في
الاولويات بالنسبه
للقرار الروسي هذا انسحاب عملاني وليس
تكتيك ولكن قد يكون له مبررات واولويات في
المرحله القادمه
هل سيكون
الوضع عند الضفه اليسرى لنهر ديني برو
يعني بعد الانسحاب
وبناء خطوط دفاع جديده هل يمكن ان يكون
وضع القوات الروسيه هناك افضل ميدانيا
بالطبع اولا بالمعنى الميداني القدره
الاوكرانيه اليوم مع الصواريخ الجديده
قادره على ضرب كل التجمعات كل مراكز الثقل
ولكن بالحد الادنى نهر النيبرو يامن عازل
طبيعي مهم جدا يحمي القوات الروسيه على
سبيل المثال يتراوح عرض النهر بين ال 400
متر وصولا الى اثنين كيلو متر
وهذا الامر يعطي مجال اساسي بالاضافه الى
هذا الامر هناك ما يسمى باقتصاد القوى
ويجب ان ننتقل من هذه المرحله حسن الى
زفروديا الى المنطقه الشرقيه الى الدنباز
يعني يجب ان نربط هذا ما يحصل يوم بما قد
يحصل في الشر في المنطقه الشرقيه او
الدباس خاصه
بمخموطوف وكريمينا كل مرتبط مع بعضه البعض
ولكن يبقى المرحله القادمه بماذا ستاتي من
اولويات الروس
وسؤالي هنا كان سؤالي التالي يتعلق بمنطقه
شرق الاخرى لماذا
القوات الروسيه يعني لم تستطع الحفاظ على
مواقعها كما يبدو في الضفه الغربيه لنهر
دينيبرو
وبماذا تختلف هذه الجبهه مثلا على اهميتها
بالنسبه للجانب الروسي عن الجبهات الاخرى
في دونيسك ولوغانسك
في المرحله الاولى من الحرب خرسان سقطت
اول اقليم اليوم كان الهدف الانطلاق من
خرسان باتجاه مايكوليف وصولا الى اوديسا
ولكن الامور كلها تبدلت بسبب اخطاء سياسيه
جيوستراتيجيه وحتى في التنفيذ العسكري لها
اسباب اخرى ليس من المجال الحديث عنها
حاليا بعد هذا الجمود لا يمكن بالمعنى
العسكري البقاء في هذه المدينه معزوله عن
الخلفيه الاساسيه حيث اللوجستيه يعني
عندما اتى سلاح الهايمر على سبيل المثال
دمر كل الجسور خاصه ان تنفسكي وحتى منع
الجسور الصغيره من التواصل مع اقليم خرسان
بعبور النهر والوصول الى همم مدينه خرسان
فازل اصبح ما يقارب 30,000 جندي معزولين
عن القاعده العسكريه اللوجيسيه الخاصه
فيها كل ما يمد بصله من هنا تم نقل هذه
القوات الى المنطقه الشرقيه شكرا لك العمي
يسحن لنا الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
حدثنا من بيروت